around 7 20 this evening as stabbing  took place right behind me here at this  apartment complex this is a Holiday Inn  now Metro stating that some type of  physical fight took place inside of one  of the apartments now in that complex a  mother and her kids two of the kids got  into some type of verbal altercation and  started fighting that's when the mother  and her boyfriend who was also in the  apartment complex with her tried to  break up the fight one of the children  got a knife and then stabbed the  boyfriend we are told the boyfriend is a  black man in his 40s he was taken to  Sunrise where he later died currently  there are no outstanding suspects in  this case but of course keep it here on  8 news now for the latest details  sending it back to you